I mean Sally this are you gonna arm
workout yeah yeah can I help you yeah
you wanna I will help you see if I'm
kidding okay let's see
oh my God
Sally Field this is very heavy it is
very heavy no I swear it is it really is
though I'm fine now I do a really good
interview this way
well congratulations so much
be up there to be recognized in this way
huh what do you mean to be up there and
be recognized in this way it felt great
yeah it must have of course yeah and not
to mention I mean you had Andrew
Garfield up there paying tribute to you
Austin Butler help you up the stairs all
these handsome men around you yeah yeah
oh that's the way it goes folks what was
your reaction when you heard Andrew say
that the Flying Nun was his first
superhero movie
and your amazing amazing career is there
a moment or a role or even you know an
ensemble that stands out to you where
you're like you know what that was a
good time and I'm so glad I did that
you know no I can't I I mean I've been
lucky enough to be a part of so many
films first of all that had ensembles I
just did one that had an ensemble that
was so fun I mean still Magnolias was so
fun 80 for Brady was so much fun but
then other movies like whether it's you
know Mrs Doubtfire or forest or you know
just so many that the group the actors
together
are so great to be around you just don't
want to go home at night well that's not
true you do want to go home at night
like is it over yet can we get out of
here but it's just that good luck that's
something back in oh is it okay if I
leave for a minute no I wouldn't mean to
pay tribute to her tonight oh my God it
was responsible for me
she's she's my sorry some kind of
surrogate something in my life I don't
know we created a bond we can't it's a
relationship that just continues the
minute we see each other he's like can I
help you are you okay you want to stay I
think we need you guys in another
project together
um it was on honestly an honor like a
true true honor to like no because these
these moments sorry yeah no these
moments are very rare and to be asked by
someone that I admire and hold in the
highest regard as as a North star of of
what we do and as a human being and uh
full of I'm into all the humility
together
I love you thank you I'll see you back
you can be okay yeah no I'm not don't
leave me what a perfect gentleman that
guy is yes and he's spectacular I mean
he's just he's a spectacular actor he is
one of the actors of his generation he
just need he's his work because I've
seen everything he's done on stage uh
and Tick Tick boom last year I I mean
for me I I thought that he was
incredible it was the performance of the
year it was my feeling but
you know he's a second away from
a place he probably doesn't want to be
in reality but you are right because I
know him as an actor he's um
he is so great to work with you know
yeah real quick you know this year marks
the 30th anniversary of Mrs Doubtfire
actually
um what did that movie mean to you and
have you noticed that you're lying the
whole time has taken on a new life on
the internet do you know that no I don't
watch that really yes because it's the
perfect line delivery of the whole time
the whole time well it's also the
comedic part of it was that I said it
calmly I said it four times four
different ways for a different time yeah
you see it so it was a comedic moment
yeah it wasn't a comedic moment when I
did it but I sort of found a way into it
foreign